мама Наталія донька Яна та син Ярослав у
такому ж складі торік 8 квітня вони в
трьох тікаючи від війни намагалися
виїхати з Краматорська саме тоді Росія
вдарила по вокзалу балістичної ракетою з
касетною боєголовкою
Наталія втратила ліву ногу а є 11-річна
донька обидві ноги Ну я збиралася
виїжджати і не збиралась то вже время
потім подзвонив чоловік каже
Собирайся потому що буде
ще хуже
но у нас тоді ще таких прильотів не було
ми тільки могли дивитися як на васеловку
бомбили було видно
дитиночка така маленька
півтора року тому їм здавалося що звичне
життя закінчилося Нині ж як колись вони
знову можуть вийти на прогулянку ба
більше Яна вже пробігла свій перший
півмарафон
понад рік степаненки провели у сан-дієго
Яна та Наталія пройшли протезування в
одній з найкращих клінік США теж було
поначалу Конечно Ну потім якось так
звикли
Яночко ходила у нас десь два жовтня
потім
получилось так щоб трошки
після оцих операцій штут робили десь там
їй трохи закрутили нерв і вони почались
болі
опять же ці клініки все вирішили що
треба оперувати 4 ноября і прооперували
загалом Яна перенесла три операції
останньо робили вже у Сполучених Штатах
Я не була перша - це після ці трагедії
друга була у Львові
їй прибирали косточку бо для
протезування вона була зайвою там вообще
її треба було прибрати просто не могла
ходити прибрали і третю вона вже
перенесла в Штатах Та попри усі
Випробування Яна з посмішкою згадує
перебування в Америці це Це я а це мама
це ми каталась на горках і нам забув
таке
це взагалі дуже страшно було дуже Так я
там взагалі кричала просто кажу і хоча
Степаненко мали можливість залишитися у
США все ж вирішили повернутися до
України
займмували за тим же хлібом мама в них
такого хліба теж сало ми купували там і
нова нова Ця з нашим сюди приїхали Я вже
вам набрала і стала і нас всього щоб
дітям готувати було все
анів на майбутнє Наталія нині не будує
проте каже Хоче хоча б на день поїхати
додому у Донецькій нью-йорк якийсь
щоденно під ударами РФ там досі
залишається її рідна тітка Ми жили в
новоселівці рядом з нашими Йорком потім
ми купили дом тут в нью-йорке 16
-му році ми переїхали діти пішли в школу
туда в садочок сначала ходили потім
пішли в школу Тут жили Все було
нормально все було гарно
діти росла собі бігали гулялось їздили
до бабусі До нашої то давно веселівку
нині немає Ані дому Ані бабусі мама
Наталії загинула торік під час
російського обстрілу
прилетів снаряд
ми хотіли я тут конечно забрать А у них
уже не було на зв'язку ну Свєта не було
телефон так ото заряджали Люди де Ну
кого генератор була надто заряджала вже
не додзвонитися А на слідуючий день
знаком мене аж поїхав туда він каже вони
вмієте уговаривать
він поїхав даже не сказав нам що він
поїде Тоню забирати і він уже її привез
привіз получається мертву
тому що 22
Це вбила її
І була там ще сусіда Женю чоловік
Наталії тобто від чим близнюків який
воював у лавах ЗСУ також загинув на
війні
він з 15-го року воював
от як там його призвали
в цьому познайомились Ну там 16-17 він
то военкоматі то і він тільки в январе-
22 у нього
контракт закінчився і він тільки 29
січня чи що приїхав додому всю Ми уже
думали всьо там побуде якийсь там 4-5
місяців вдома вона там віддихає потім
може піде десь на роботу і тут це от
нині Степаненко і живуть у Львові тут я
не готується до заміни
протезатор
нічого все окей нормально новий протест
для Яни мають виготовити У майстерні
реабілітаційного центру Незламні проте
за доведеться змінювати щороку аж доки
Яна не перестане рости кожний зв'язку з
тим що Яночка росте її форма тіла
постійно змінюється змінюється форма ніг
їй потрібно буде ще кілька разів
змінювати її протези і зараз в неї саме
не став той період часу коли потрібно
знову знімати нові мірки і розпочинати
процес виготовлення нових протезів які я
маю надію прослужить її хоча б ще потім
рік часу
перед уяни ще одна реабілітація А у
Наталії як голови сім'ї надважлива місія
влаштувати комфортне життя для дітей
поки що родина Житиме у Львові Утім
Степаненко вірять Одного дня поїдуть
додому бо Хоч вони й побували в Америці
але найбільше мріють повернутися в свій
український
нью-йорк